siamo soli nonostante l'ultimo decennio
sia stato caratterizzato dalla più
grande rivoluzione della comunicazione
ed al consolidamento della tecnologia
digitale
siamo una generazione di persone sole
la grande ascesa delle piattaforme
social ci ha dato la possibilità di
metterci in contatto in tempo reale con
persone dall'altra parte del mondo ci ha
fornito gli strumenti per scambiarci
foto video creare chat di gruppo gruppi
chiusi video colla insomma per sentirci
vicini nonostante i chilometri di
distanza
ma tutto questo non è servito a portare
benefici che speravamo di avere con
l'avvento dei social infatti con il
passare degli anni i social sono
diventati essenziali necessarie proprio
come se fossero una droga e noi fruitori
di questi mezzi così affascinanti quanto
pericolosi abbiamo smesso di utilizzarli
in modo sano e positivo ci siamo fatti
forza dello schermo che ci separa dalla
realtà
abbiamo sconfitto la timidezza e ne
siamo diventati succubi pensiamo di
averne preso il controllo ma sotto il
nostro controllo non c'è assolutamente
nulla nell'odio che ogni giorno viene
versato nell'arroganza che caratterizza
la nostra generazione e questo purtroppo
non è un bene non è un bene perché se da
un lato nella vita reale fatichiamo a
fare un sorriso quando un automobilista
ci dà la precedenza a malapena diamo il
buongiorno al barista che ci prepara il
caffè al mattino o raramente ci fermiamo
qualche minuto a casa per sapere come
stanno i nostri genitori quando ci
trasformiamo nel nostro alter ego social
siamo invece i primi a prendere parola
sfruttato un post ad essere protagonisti
della conversazione
e a giudicare questo perché lo schermo
che ci separa dalla realtà ci ha dato
forza quella forza e quel coraggio che
abbiamo smesso di utilizzare nella vita
reale e che alimentiamo esclusivamente
on line le piattaforme social ci fanno
sentire invincibile ci fanno sentire
superiori e sempre dalla parte del
giusto ci danno il diritto di giudicare
qualsiasi cosa
e qualsiasi persona a prescindere che ci
sia stato chiesto il nostro parere a
prescindere dalla nostra ignoranza
riguardo le piattaforme social hanno
guadagnato e ci hanno fatto guadagnare
il diritto di parola
lungi da me e da dire che questo non sia
un diritto primario è sacrosanto
dell'essere umano ma la socialdemocrazia
non è uguale al diritto di parola al
diritto di poter giudicare sempre e
comunque
qualcun altro amico non senza portare
rispetto
il filtro che avevamo nella vita reale
sui social media non esiste più e quando
una persona perde il filtro della
timidezza dell'arroganza e soprattutto
dell'etica quello che ne esce fuori è il
luogo più pericoloso in cui poter vivere
ed è il luogo in cui noi oggi viviamo e
nel quale vivranno i nostri figli per
molto tempo ancora
pensate a quasi 4 miliardi di persone
che quotidianamente abitano le
piattaforme social come facebook twitter
tik tok instagram matrice youtube e
scrivono contenuti o pubblicano video
senza filtri
aggiungeteci e le testate di
informazione e soprattutto di
disinformazione i contenuti e
sponsorizzati dalle aziende gli account
fake personaggi pubblici politici gli
influencer immaginate ora che questi 4
miliardi di abitanti
trascorrono circa 2 ore e 20 in media al
giorno sui social e se questo numero può
sembrarvi elevato controllate voi stessi
ed al vostro smartphone
il tempo trascorso sulle app social e
poi ricordatevi che all'interno di
questa media ci sono tantissime persone
con comportamenti molto diversi tra loro
come ad esempio le filippine dove la
media del tempo trascorso sale a quasi 4
ore oppure in brasile con tre ore e
mezzo al giorno oppure ancora come gli
appartenenti alla generazione z con
circa tre ore al giorno a tutto questo
poi aggiungiamo una quantità
spropositata di contenuti a cui
quotidianamente siamo
sui social media su facebook ad esempio
vengono pubblicati circa 41.000 posta al
secondo su youtube si caricano circa 72
ore di video ogni singolo minuto mentre
su twitter ogni singolo minuto vengono
pubblicati 278 mila tweet e infine su
instagram si pubblicano 3mila 600 posta
al secondo
ecco stiamo parlando di centinaia di
milioni di contenuti social pubblicati
ogni giorno a cui abbiamo accesso senza
controllo e nei filtri contenuti e
conversazioni che contengono
informazioni punti di vista opinioni che
si vanno a nascondere nel nostro
cervello e contribuiscono a formare il
nostro pensiero come teorizzava bosman
circa 20 anni fa la vita moderna è una
successione ininterrotta di nuovi inizi
per questo li la definisce una vita
liquida ovvero una vita precaria vissuta
in condizione di continua incertezza con
la paura di essere colti alla sprovvista
di rimanere indietro di dimenticare di
perdere il momento della svolta e
superare il punto di non ritorno dove
ciò che conta è la velocità con cui
facciamo le cose e non più la durata
eccola la teoria di bowman descrive
perfettamente la trasformazione della
nostra quotidianità
con l'avvento del digitale e soprattutto
delle piattaforme social infatti siamo
diventati incapaci di rallentare il
ritmo di questo cambiamento di
prevederne e controllarne e la direzione
è per questo che abbiamo innescato dei
meccanismi inconsci di autodifesa
non a caso cerchiamo di calcolare e
minimizzare i rischi di cadere vittime
di pericoli indefinibili
cerchiamo di autodiagnosticarsi malattie
inesistenti
cerchiamo sempre il modo di confutare
certezze attraverso banalissime
supposizioni
cerchiamo bersagli su cui scaricare
l'eccesso di paura odio e rabbia che non
trovano più naturale via di sfogo nel
mondo offline con così tante
informazioni in circolazione
sui social stiamo diventando persone
sempre più disinformate non sappiamo più
a cosa credere
tutta questa sovraesposizione ai
contenuti digitali questa frenesia
danneggia il nostro pensiero ci rende
deboli individualisti aggressivi ci ha
dato la possibilità di renderci persone
arrabbiate con una carica di odio sempre
maggiore è sempre più persone infatti
danno il loro appoggio incondizionato
alle fick news ai populismi al
negazionismo a chi incita all'odio a
razzismo al sessismo ad esempio
un'analisi dell'agicom fra marzo e
maggio sulle conversazioni e attività
associa alla relativa al coronavirus ha
evidenziato come gli utenti facebook
abbiano mostrato molto più interesse
verso contenuti negazionisti
complottisti e falsi rispetto a quelli
istituzionali e scientifici sul co lead
19 poi arriva il caso del cantante
sergio silvestre durante la finale di
coppa italia
in questo caso si tratta di un classico
esempio di sci storm dove migliaia di
italiani hanno insultato sui social
senza filtri
un ragazzo visibilmente emozionato che
cantava l'inno d'italia riempiendo i
feed di facebook e twitter
gli insulti razzisti e body shen ying
infine pochi giorni fa la virologa
ilaria capua è stata ricoperta di
insulti per alcune dichiarazioni in
televisione sul co ed insulti sessisti
ovviamente privi di motivazione che
anche questo caso si sostituiscono ad un
confronto sano alimentando invece l'odio
e la cattiveria
ecco questi sono soltanto alcuni esempi
recenti e un po più illustri di xp ma
dobbiamo ricordarci che ogni giorno
l'odio è presente nelle bacheche social
di tutti noi e colpisce sempre più
individui beh a questo punto però
dobbiamo domandarci ma noi cosa possiamo
fare per contrastare questo fenomeno è
ancora possibile affrontare faccia a
faccia questa sfida
io credo che non bastino più le campagne
di denuncia come ad esempio la campagna
black list sneijder o le azioni dei
brand o dei personaggi pubblici che
decidono di cancellare il proprio
account dei social per protesta dobbiamo
cambiare dobbiamo ricominciare a fare
communiqué c'è bisogno di un'azione da
parte di tutti quanti noi in realtà
potremmo iniziare oggi stesso
ipotizziamo di essere circa 200 persone
oggi ad assistere a questo video beh se
ognuno di noi ogni giorno facesse due
buone azioni sui social e convincesse
almeno una persona a fare lo stesso in
una sola settimana saremo oltre 12.000
persone mentre non mese potremmo
arrivare ad avere oltre 100 miliardi di
commenti positivi sulle bacheche social
ovviamente stiamo parlando solo di
numeri certo ma questo ci fa capire
quanto possa essere forte il potere di
una community quanto insieme è possibile
contrastare l'odio facendo del bene
io credo che possiamo ancora salvarci
perché viaggiamo insieme non saremo più
soli